e
herkese merhaba hepinize muhteşem bir
tediks günü diliyorum ve başlayalım
günümüzde aşkım aktive ile başlayalım
bir gazeteci yormak sivil sadece olan
olayları olduğu gibi aktaran değildir
aynı zaman da düşündüren kızdıran yeri
gelince de aksiyona geçiren dir bunu
söylediği Yıllar 1800'lü yıllar ve marty
ve bir Amerikalı
1900'lü yıllara geldiğimizde orada da
Hindistan bağımsızlık hareketinin lideri
mahat magandi
kamuoyunu anlama da tanımada
gazeteciliğin önemine vurgu yapıyor işte
böyle Dünyanın farklı coğrafyalarında
farklı tarihlerde dönemlerde kendisini
merak duygusuyla besleyen o merak
duygusu ile birlikte doğru bilgiye
ulaşmaya çalışan ve doğru bilgiye
ulaşıldıkça da sizlere Ak bu destek
bizimkisi gazetecilik Bana da merak
duygusunun tohumları beş yaşına kadarki
süreçte atıldı Hani Uzmanlar değerlerle
gelecekte vereceğimiz kararlar
alacağımız atacağımız adımlar o Yedi
yaşına kadarki süreçte belirlenir diye
Ben de dolmuşlar beş yaşına kadarki
süreçte Babam asker olduğu için onun
görevi nedeniyle Bizlerde doğuda yaydık
şark görevi nedeniyle Doğu duaydık 80'li
yıllar terörün en yoğun olduğu dönemler
ve çok net hatırlıyorum camları bile
açmak yasaktı Acaba dışarıdan bomba
atılır mı diye bazı günler olurdu ki
acaba babamız eve sağ dönecek mi diye
kapılarda beklerdik biz çocuklar Hani
camdan bakmak yasak ya işte o süreçte
yaşadıklarım sonrasında yaşadıklarım
güçlü mücadeleci bir anne ve babadan
geliyor olma bana yaşadıklarımı
sorgulatmak için bu yönde bir meslek
seçtirdi ve gazeteci oldu meslek
hayatının bu ile dönemlerinde stajyer
dönemlerinde 1999 yılıydı Ankara TRT
Haber merkezinde başladım O zaman
Başbakan Bülent Ecevit Tea her Parti
takip eden farklı farklı muhabirler
vardı ve o Maviler düzenlenen basın
toplantılarında en iyi soruyu sormak en
zor soruyu sormak için birbirleriyle
adeta yarışır lardı sonra tv8de İstaş
Erlik dönemi derken profesyonel anlamda
meslek hayatıma Mehmet Ali Birand'ın ve
mm yanında Kanal D Haber'de başladım o
zamanlar Mehmet Ali birand'a sordu güçlü
sorularıyla tanıyordu Türkiye sadece
dünya liderlerine dediği Türk liderlere
de güçlü sorular yöneltiyor ve farklı
farklı liderler de bir araya getiriyordu
aynı programda işte bir tarafına mesela
Mesut Yılmaz Tansu çiller'i oturuyordu
diğer tarafını Alparslan Türkeş'i Bülent
Ecevit'i sadece Mehmet Ali Birand da
değil Yine ekollerden Ali Kırca reham bu
Savaş Ay Mithat Bereket Uğur Dündar
birbirleriyle en iyi soruyu sormak için
adet Ah yarış halindedir Erdoğan
atmosferin son dönemlerini yakalayan bir
gazeteci olarak ben de yıllarca Kanal D
Haber'de çalıştım muhabir olarak
sonrasında CNN TÜRK derken Londra'da bir
birisini ise kabul edildim sonra TRT
Türk'ün ilk Erbil temsilcisi oldum
derken Habertürk haber spikerliği
program sunuculuğu
ya Çalıştığım süre zarfında pek çok çok
dünya lideri ile bakanlığa başbakanlığa
cumhurbaşkanıyla özel röportajlar yaptım
ve tecrübelerin bana şunu gösterdi iyi
sorular genelde verilen cevaplardan daha
güçlüdür işte bugün bunu konuşacağız
Yani gazeteciliğin dünden bugüne nasıl
Dünyada ve Türkiye'de evrildiğini
değiştiğini o güçlü soruların nasıl
giderek güçsüzleşti ni konuşacağız 3D
o
orada görevim sırasında
farklı farklı dönemlerde yine bir yıla
yakın Irak da yaşadım dönemleri
birleştirdiğimizde o zaman Amerika'nın
Irak operasyonları vardır ve o filmlere
konu olan Black kol helikopterleri ile
Amerikan askerleriyle birlikte ırağın
üstüne operasyon bölgesini üstünde
uçuşumuz dünyada ilk olarak anılan
haberlerinden ya da bir yıla yakın
Gazze'de kaldım farklı farklı
dönemlerine birleştirdiğimizde orada
Hamas ve El Fetih arasındaki iç savaşı
aktaran tek Türk gazeteciyim gözümüzün
önünde onlarca sivil ölürken onlarca
kişi yaralanırken İsrail hepimizden
fosfor bombaları yağdırırken Mısır
üzerinden Gazze'ye girende ile ilk Türk
gazeteciyim bir başka hatırladığım
haberim de Suriye'den o Suriyeli meşhur
dolan tepelerin eteklerinde
hayalet Kent Knight ra insansız Kent
Konakları 1967 Savaşı'ndan o ilk
girişimimiz yine dünyada ilk olarak
yayınlanan haberlerinden bir tane siydi
sonra Afganistan Pakistan Mısır Malezya
Kırgızistan Gürcistan Rusya Savaşı
derken 17'den farklı ülkede kritik
zamanlarda
görev yaptım ve Biraz önce de
belirttiğim gibi bu sürede Biz
gazeteciler için yani sahada çalışan Biz
gazeteciler için fark yaratmak önemlidir
ve o farkı yaratmak için hep en tepeye
ulaşmaya çalışırız liderlerle
röportajlar yapmaya çalışırız
Ben de gelenekleri takip ederek o entepe
ulaşmaya çalışanlar dın işin açıkçası
Türkiye'de ve dünyada biz böyle değişen
Rotası değişen rüzgarın etkisiyle sağa
sola savruluyoruz derken yine de iyimser
olmaya çalışıyorum ve yine de herkese
her sorunun sorulabilecek yine inanmak
istiyorum inanıyorum çünkü daha
öncesinde bu oldu ve bu yapıldı yine
kendimden örnek vereyim mesela Yeri
geldi şu PKK ile mücadelede İran
Türkiye'nin yanında diye açıklamalar
yapılırken böyle manşetler atılırken
herkesin içerisinde dönemin İran
Cumhurbaşkanı Ahmedinejad Tabii Peki
İran'daki Peugeot Kaplanı neden
kapatıyorsunuz kapatacak mısınız diye
sordu geri geldi Hamas lideri Mahmut
ejderha araba El Kaide ve Taliban dan
yardım alıyor musunuz dedim o zamana
kadar bir Hamas liderinin ağzından bu
yönde yapılan Bir açıklamada olmamıştı
ve ilk defa o röportajda Hamas lideri El
kaydeden destek aldığını kabul etmiştir
Yeri geldi Gürcistan Rusya Savaşı'nda ve
Gürcistan devlet başkanı Mihail
saakaşvili ile röportaj yaparken sağ
kaşığı kendini böyle
savunuyor işte ve öbürlerine öbürleri
Ben ülkemi Atatürk gibi savunuyorum
derken ya dedim röportaj esnasında bir
saniye elinizde egzamalar görüyorum ve o
kravatınızı ısırırken ki görüntülerinizi
hatırlıyorum Bunlar stresten mi Atatürk
ülkeyi böyle korkarak savunma the
benzetmez doğru mu dedim bir yeri geldi
bölgesel kürt yönetimi lideri mesela
Mesut Barzani sorularımı karşımda ciddi
ciddi yanıtlarken bir dakika dedim ya
yine röportaj esnasında neden bu kadar
ciddisin iz ben sizden korkusunu
istiyorsunuz dedi Mesut Barzani bastı
kahkahayı röportaj esnasında
İşte bu süreçte Bizler herkese her soru
sorulabilir ve sorduğumuz soruların
yanıtları cevapları alınır diyorduk tabi
bizler için sorduğumuz soruların yanında
herkese her soruyu sonra bilmenin
yanında o sorduğumuz soruların
cevaplarını da alabilmek önemli yıl
2007'yi Uzun zaman sonra Türkiye Irak'ın
kuzeyine hava Harekatı akabinde de kara
harekatı düzenleyecek de hava harekâtı
sırasında gazeteci olarak bölgede
çalışıyordum Erbil Süleymaniye Zaho git
gel ama yine de fark yaratmaya
çalışanlar da da o entepe lideri
ulaşmaya çalışanlardan dönemin Irak
cumhurbaşkanı Celal Talabani dedi Celal
talabani'nin Türkiye'ye gelemez giremez
kendi bir süreçti ve Celal Talabani
içinde bir Türk gazeteciler röportaj
yapmak asla bakarsanız riskli bir işte
bu video portaj talepleri yapmaya
başladım oraya mail buraya mail oraya
bir buraya bir cevap yok cevap yok
dönemde Türkiye Üç gün kala koskoca bir
hayır Yazısı geldi Hadi odada itiraf
edeyim hayatımda Hayır yarısını aldığımı
bu kadar da sevindim hatırlamıyorum işin
açıkçası çünkü Bundan sonraki süreçte
artık kiminle muhatap olmam gerektiğini
biliyordum
Hayır ya da geldi Türkiye'ye döndük
İzinli olduğum bir gün Televizyon açık
yine patron karşında biraz bir baktım
karşısında Celal Talabani telefon
bağlantısı yapıyor ve o yayında Celal
Talabani bir Kürt kedisini bile vermem
demişti Mehmet Ali birand'a ben röportaj
taleplerini yineledi mi Bu arada artık
en sonunda konu talebe ama ne kadar
gitmiş tane Anne demiş ki ya Kim bu
çatlak böyle vazgeçmiyor bir türlü
gelsin ben tabi patronun odasına girdi
Madem Talabani ile röportaj yapmaya
gidiyorum şöyle bir yarım aldım güldü
baktı git bari dedi tamam bu saydık ama
yine de tatlı bir rekabet her zaman
meslektaşlar arasında vardır Bağdat'a
gittik havaalanında bir baktım
karşımızda böyle onlarca [ __ ] araç
bize karşılamaya gelmişler şaşırdım ilk
başta Hadi ne gerek vardı peki
Teşekkürler Biz şu otelde kalacağız
olmaz dediler e Nerede kalacağız
talabani'nin evinde şimdi bir gazeteci
için muazzam bir fırsat sadece röportaj
yapmak da kalmayacaksın aynı zamanda
talabani'nin evini de görüntüleme
haberleştirme fırsatım olacak da gittik
yerleştirmiş arada bir saat geçti
geçmedi kapım ısrarla çalınmaya başladı
yaveri yardımcısı kapıyı açtım röportaj
iptal dedi ya dedim neden iptal Ata
İstanbul'dan buraya kadar geldik patron
o kadar hava attım falan ip tane de
söyle bana Gitti Nereye gitti Irak'ın
kuzeyine Süleymaniye gitti bilmiyoruz ne
zaman dönecek bilmiyoruz
biz buna gazeteci yüzsüzlüğü dediniz
büyük bir gazeteci yüzsüzlüğü ile peki
dedim Talabani dön bu fark Biz burada
bekleriz biz Yaklaşık 15 günle yediğimiz
önümüzde yemediğimiz arkamızda Celal
talabani'nin evinde yanımızda tabi
[ __ ] Korumalar bağdatta özel haber
üzerine özel haber yaptık sana Bari
Baktı ki biz dönüyoruz dedi ki gelsinler
onun özel uçağıyla o zaman
Amerikalıların uçağı vardır bırak pilotu
kullanıyordu Süleymaniye gittik
beni ilk gördüğünde kapıda şunu sordu ya
bu röportajı çok mu istediğin dedi Evet
dedim Çok istedim şimdi sana öyle
başlıklar öyle manşetler vereceğim ki
Türkiye haftalarca aylarca
bunları konuşacak
bu Türkiye'ye gelemez giremez dinlen
Celal Talabani İlk defa o röportajda
hangi tarihte Türkiye'ye geleceğini
söyledi Mehmet Ali bir hafta yaptığı
yayında Bir Külkedisi bile vermem diyen
Celal Talabani İlk defa o röportajda PKK
bir terörist örgüt türdedir İlk defa o
röportajda bağımsız bir Kürt devleti Ne
inanmadığını söyledi son dönemlerde
Biraz önce de belirttiğim gibi biz
gazeteciler ya öte herkese her soruyu
çatır çatır soruyoruz cevaplarını da
alıyoruz derken ben 2008 yılında birşey
oldu Türkiye'de 2008 yılında Ergenekon
davası gerçekleşti ve ortada müthiş bir
bilgi kirliliği vardı Neyin doğru neyin
yanlış olduğu belli değil de biz
gazeteciler için de doğru bilgiye
ulaşmak son derece zordu
2008 Ergenekon davasıyla birlikte
Türkiye'de hafta atılan gazetecilerin
sayısında artış görülmeye başladı al
Böyle olunca da Bu mesleğin bazı
üstadları geriye çekildiler bazıları da
sadece yediği yemeği gittiği mekanı
yazar hale geldiler zaman içerisinde
araştırmacı gazeteci kavramı da önemini
yitirmeye başladı O güne kadar sahada
hazırlanan haberler Arena gibi 32 Gün
Gibi Pusula A Takımı gibi Haberler Ya
kaldırıldılar ya da formatları değişmeye
başladı bu
o format Ne oldu malum halihazırda
izlediğiniz gibi stüdyoda yayınlanan o
tartışma programları popüler hale
gelmeye başladı çünkü Türkiye'nin merak
ettiğim bir konuydu Ergenekon davası
sonra kanal yönetimleri kanal sahipleri
bir baktılar ki sucuda hazırlanan o
tartışma programları son derece maliyet
siz ya da daha az maliyeti bu defa
vücuda hazırlanan tartışma programları
tamamen akışlarda yer almaya başladı Siz
izleyicilerin o yayın akışında
belirlemede çok da söz hakkınız olmadığı
için Sizler de size sunulan neyse onu
izlemek durumunda kaldınız hattâ O güne
kadar o döneme kadar sahadan hazırlanan
32 Gün bile stüdyoda hazırlanan bir
haber programı formatında dönüştük
zamanla soru tarzı da değişmeye başladı
usluca da hazırlanan tartışma
programlarının vücuda yapılan
röportajlarda bir zamanlarda Aman
efendim Peki efendim ile başlayan
sorular görmeye başladı var ya da enişte
mesela bilinçli olarak analizden uzak bu
konu hakkında Siz ne düşünüyorsunuz ya
da yatak Bu Böyle söylemiş Siz ne
diyeceksiniz diye biten genel geçer
sorularla karşılaşır olduk
bu
mobilin Acar dönemleri yine yine
unutmadım örneklerden bir tanesi
hayatımda sokak röportajları yapmak için
dışarı çıkmıştım ya Kanal D'de
çalıştığım bir dönemlerde röportajları
yaptım haberi hazırladım geldim Evde
programda habere girdi haber bitti eve
döneceğiz asansörün kapısının önünde
patronla karşılaştığım bir atasözü ve 5
karış asit o neydi ya öyle dedi taksi
şoförüyle muhabbet ediyorsun Anlamadım
şekerim dedi Siz ne düşünüyorsunuz diye
biten gazeteci sorusu olur mu Ben yine
anlamadım ya dedi Bir analiz yeteneği
birşeyin olsun yani hiç öyle ucu açık
gazeteci sorusu olur mu
bu sizce olur mu
bu işte böyle dövüle dövüle dövüle
zamanlı soru sormayı öğrendik derken
bugüne geldiğimizde bugün halen
mesleğimde Türkiye'de farklı farklı
liderlerle Türk liderliğini röportajlar
yapmaya devam ediyorum Türkçesi şu da
benim için bir kazanım her tarafla
görüşe biliyorum kapılar her taraftan
açıp bu güzel bir şey sanıyorum böyle
karşılıklı güven duygusundan
kaynaklanıyor ama öte taraftan bir başka
konu bizleri üzüyor Yani bu programa
çıkmaz burada röportaj vermez şuna
konuşmaz gibi fikir ve eylemler
Hem bizi üzüyor hem de elimizi kolumuzu
bağlıyor Oysa muhatap olduğumuz
tarafları bir gazetecinin tek amacının
sormak sorgulamak anlamak ve o bilgiyi
sizlere aktarmak olduğuna inansa ve Bunu
bilse Neden herkes her kanala çıkması
iki
bir de bize yöneltilen önyargılar var
sadece gazetecileri değil Aslı bu
gazeteciler muhatapların muhatapların
gazetecilere önerdiği önyargılarım
yargılar demiş kendi Amerika Birleşik
devletlerinden bir örnek vereyim Orada
da bir önceki Amerikan başkanı dağıtılan
pandomin ilk zamanlarını bir basın
toplantısı düzenledi ve basın
toplantısına dana trampa bir soru
yöneltmek istedi çekik gözlü bir
gazeteci ve pekin'in Amerika'ya yaptığı
yardımları sormak istedi daha Trabzon
şöyle bir baktı Sen de de Çin medyasına
mı çalışıyorsun hayır dedi şekil göz
gazeteci ben Hong Kong meyvesini
çalışıyorum hayır dedi Sen Çin
medyasında çalışıyorsun şak aldık için
medyasına çalışsan olur artık bu sorunun
içeriğinde de ne var Bir diğer konu
ithamlar ithamlar
Arabi gazeteci için bu bütün
meslektaşlarım için geçerli biliyorum
farklı farklı taraflarla görüşebilmek
önemlidir işte yine kendi yeni değerli
bir şey bizim için kıymetli geldiğimde
Ben böyleyim işte geri geliyor mesela
bir gün İran Cumhurbaşkanı ile özel
röportaj yapıp İlerleyen bir süreçte
Suudi Arabistan'ın üst düzey bir bakanı
ile görüşmek bir gün Rusya başbakanı ile
röportaj yapmam İlerleyen bir dönemde
NATO komutanı ile görüşmek aynı gün
içerisinde Hamas lideri İsrail Ordu
sözcüsü Elif eti sözlüsüyle ya da
lideriyle buluşabilmek bir gazeteci için
anlatılmaz biraz Anlatılmaz yaşanır
derler yani o misera bu defa da halk
arasında Biz şöyle şeylerle karşılaşmaya
başladık ya bu her tarafla görüşüyor
ajan mıdır nedir Ha tabi ki her tarafta
görüşeceğiz her tarafta görüşebilirim
haber kaynaklarımız farklı olsun ki
doğru bilgiyi aktarabilirim buraya
gelmişken bir örnek iletmek istiyorum
yine patrondan bugün çok kırılmışım
ne derler ya çınlattık Allah rahmet
eylesin İki gün bu gece liderler
zirvesinde o liderlerimiz de hemen
tanıtayım Aslında kıdem sırasına göre
Müsade ederseniz tanıtacağım Sayın
Alparslan Türkeş sayın Bülent Ecevit
Sayın Mesut Yılmaz Esat kıratlıoğlu ve
Sayın
Şevket beyin Adı hep buraya yazmışım
Şevket kadar hoş geldin zaten bu gece
da yüzdeki Gülümser ifadeleri ve saygı
ortamına görüyor musunuz üstüne üstük
programa davet eden gazeteci o Parti
liderinin adını unutuyor Ama öyle
programı terk edip edin takip birden
falan hiç kimsede yok yani işte böyleydi
Türkiye Bir de o zamanlar siyasi mizah
popülerdi siyasi mizah deyince de
dönemin siyasetçilerinden Süleyman
Demirel'in o sözü gelir aklıma mizah bir
yumruktur der Ne zaman Kime nasıl
vuracağı belli olmaz Peki ne oldu Ne
değişti Yani biz nasıl bu noktaya geldik
sadece Türkiye'den bahsetmiyorum dünyada
durum çok benzer
Türkiye Amerika Birleşik Devletleri'nde
bu yakın zaman öncesine kadar yapılan
seçimleri çok yakından takip ettiği için
oradan bir örnek verip aslına bakarsanız
orada gelenek değişmedi Yani yine hala
liderler taşı karşıya gelip karşı
karşıya gelmekten korkmuyorlar karşı
karşıya gelip halkın karşısında bas bu
açısında çatır çatır siyaset yapıyorlar
rekabet ediyorlar ne kazanmaya
çalışıyorlar ama orada bir üst değişmeye
başladı
2016'ya kadar pek bir sorun yok tamam
2012 yılına gittiğimizde Hatta Barack
Obama rakibi karşısında mikro mi vardı
belki siyaset sahnesinde Nezaket in
zirvesinin görüldüğü zirvesinin yaşandı
örneklerden bir tanesidir onlarda
rekabet ediyorlardı ama saygı
çerçevesinde 2016'ya geldiğimizde ne
oldu
bu sahnede yine Donald Trump diğer
tarafta ileri gelen tanıt bu defa Donald
Trump Hillary clinton'a Sen ne iğrenç
bir kadınsın diyebilir oldu Hillary
Clinton da Donald trump'a Rusya'nın
kuklası
bütün liderler için söylemiyorum tabii
ki ama sanıyorum bu dönüşüm bu Bu
kırılma Trump karakterli liderlerle
yaşanmaya başladı ve mesela basın
toplantıları düzenliyorlar adı üstünde
basın toplantısı ya o basın
toplantısında basın ötekileştirici ler
basın ötekileştirici ayrışmaya Başladı
kutuplaşmaya Başladı bizim bir ve
beraber hareket etmemiz gerekirken Çok
yakın bir zaman öncesine kadar
Türkiye'de asla bakarsanız bu şahsi
fikrim sanıyorum yapılan en büyük
hatalardan bir tanesi ve basın ve halkla
ilişkilerin birlikte Anılır olmasıydı
Hatta üniversitelerde bile basamakta
ilişkiler bölümü vardı hala Türkiye'de
bazı devlet Kurum ve kuruluşlarında
basın halkla ilişkiler daire bu mesela
birbirine tamamen tezat iki kavramdan
bahsediyoruz basın soran sorgulayan
halkla ilişkiler birşeyin tanıtımını
yapan planını yapan
ve
tarafsız bir gazeteci olarak gibi benim
gibi düşünen pek çok değerli meslektaşım
olduğunu da biliyorum röportaj yaptım
kişilerle karşı karşıya geldiğinde
mesela asla O Kişi kendinden Üstün
görmüyorum Çünkü bu bir tercih bir
Meslek tercihi daha üniversite yıllarına
dayanan ben gazeteci olmayı tercih ettim
o siyasetçi ben gazeteci o akademisyen
ben gazeteci Doktor gazeteci hukukçu ben
bundan para kazanıyor biz bundan para
kazanıyoruz onlar da ondan para
kazanıyorlar
bu
isteseydik bizde siyasetçi olurduk ama
olmadık sormayı sorgulamayı tercih ettik
Diğer Sorun da hem gazeteciler arasında
hem de halk nezdinde
acaba bazı yapıştırmaları demeyeyim de
çamları çok mu iş yerleştirdik yerde
işte cumhurbaşkanının Başbakanın bakalım
vekilim çok mu içselleştirmek biz
bunları bu vekalet edenlere asıl olan
arasındaki çizgi keskinleştir
Bu öyle değil mi
Ha bir de son 10 yılda moda haline gelen
bir durum var Hem Türkiye'de hem de
dünyada önceden soru isteme alışkanlığı
Ya alışkanlık haline geldi çünkü işte
Açıkçası ben soruları önceden
göndermiyorum bunu başlıklarında uzlaşı
yorum Çünkü sonra önceden gönderdiğimi
zaten 1-0 yenik başlamış oluyorum duruma
karşı taraf bizlerden sonra istediği
zaman bizde uyandıran İntiba şu bir
Kendine güvenmiyor iki acaba sakladığı
bir şey mi var üç konusuna hakim değil
yalnız Hadi hak yemeyelim sana
bakarsanız öyle krallar da pek sorun yok
heralde kralcılar da takılır olduk biz
yine yakın zaman öncesine kadar ki
Yaşadığım bir tecrübeyi burada paylaşmak
istiyorum Çok yakın en bildiğiniz bir
partinin lideri isim vermeyeceğim
röportaj talebinde bulunduk işte basın
danışmanı ile görüştüm 30 dakikada
anlaştık İstanbul'dan kalktık gittik
Ankara'ya röpor Az önce önceden soruları
istemediği için teşekkür ettim Yataş
başladı 16 dakikaya geldik bunu dış
politika biraz zorlanmaya başladım abim
attım benim kameranın arkasına basın
danışmanı geçmiş böyle böyle işaret
ediyor toparla bitir diye
istifimi bozmadım devam ettim çünkü 30
dakika bana aitti ama 30. dakikanın
sonunda soramadım tek bir soru kalmıştı
röportaj bitti Efendim dedim Keşke Buna
da değilse iken bunu da konuları Elif
neden Sormadınız Keşke sorsaydınız Parti
liderinin haberi yok 30 dakikada
anlaşıldığında İşte o yüzden diyorum biz
genelde kralcılar da takılıyoruz diye
şu ana kadar konuştuğumuz konuları
hayatımıza olan etkisini belki de en
önemli
gösteren en önemli etkisini gösteren bir
çalışma şimdi getireceğim o O sizin 2015
raporu oyle sey diyor ki eğer bir ülkede
basın özgürse basına yapılan yatırım
fazla ise o ülkede kişi başına düşen
milli gelir yani cebimize giren parada o
kadar fazla Eğer bir ülkede basın
özgürlüğü asla o ülke gittikçe
fakirleşiyor diyor o isiydi
Peki bundan sonraki süreçte acaba bu
durumu düzeltebiliriz düşüncesiyle neye
ihtiyacımız var Her şeyden önce size
ihtiyacımız var merak eden vatandaşa
ihtiyacımız var soran sorgulayan
eleştiren izleyici ve okuyacağı
ihtiyacımız var her konuda uzman olan
değil konusunda uzman olan kişileri daha
fazla ekranda görme ihtiyacımız var
çünkü Türkiye'de konusunda uzman olan
kişi sayısı öyle kadrolu 60 70 den daha
fazla
net sorular duymaya ihtiyacımız var yani
öyle sağlık bakanı'na işte tamam ben Biz
ne zaman açılacağı dedi Aşılar ne zaman
gelecek değil işte ben 40 yaşında bir
vatandaş olarak hangi tip aşıları hangi
tip hangi tarihten itibaren
olabileceğim sorularını duymaya
ihtiyacımız var bir televizyon programı
izlerken sorulan sorular ya da verilen
cevaplar sizi tatmin etmiyorsa
kapatın o televizyonu
artık günaha döneminde Sokrates gibi
dönüştürücü figürler öyle kitlelere
hitap ederken uzun uzun nutuklar çekmek
yerine genelde güçlü sorular sormayı
tercih etmişler Çünkü güçlü sorular
halkı düşünmeye teşvik ediyor diye
Sokrates demişken toparlamada önce
mağara benzetmesi ne değinmek istiyorum
mağara benzetmesi platon'a Sokrates
arasında geçen diyaloglar da aynı
zamanda devlet kitabında da yer buluyor
sohbete söyle diyor
gözünüzde canlandırın
özgürlüğünüz elinizden alınmış bir
mağaraya kapatılmış sınız elleriniz
arkadan Zin ne demiş yüzünüz sadece o
mağaranın duvarına bakabiliyor elleriniz
arkadan zincirli olduğu için geriye
dönemiyor sunuz sizden biraz uzakta bir
ateş yanıyor ve dışarıda nelerin olup
bittiğini o ateşin Önünden Gelip
geçenlerin önünüzdeki duvara yansıyan
gölgelerinden anlamaya çalışıyorsunuz
gerçekliği o gölgelerden çözmeye
çalışıyorsunuz aldığınızın ne kadar
kısıtlandığını farkında mısınız
bu Sokrates diyor ki gerçeklere ulaşmak
için o zincirleri kır manız ve o
mağaralardan çıkan bilmeniz lazım Çünkü
gerçekleri görmeniz buna bağlı
Biz gazeteciler sizler için herkese her
soruyu duymaya hazırız sormaya hazırız
acaba Gerçekleri duymaya Hazır mıyız
Çünkü gerçekleri duymak maddi ve yeni
söylediği gibi harekete geçmeye
gerektirir
Çok teşekkürler Ha
[Alkış]